Hello everybody and welcome to episode
number nine of my 1hour flipping
challenge. Today we're going to be
flipping Zol drops only. Um I'm a little
bit sick so this whole episode is going
to be a little quiet. I'm also recording
at like 6:00 in the morning as also a
contributing factor. We're actually
start with 30 mil today mainly because
I've actually managed to get 30 mil now.
So if you want to see me start with uh
30 mil or more uh just leave a comment
or would you prefer if I just start with
10 mil every episode? Anyway, let's get
started. Okay, here we are. We have 1
hour on the clock. We're going to be
flipping Zer drops only. Let's go. Okay,
so we're going to start
with I believe a um Tanzanite
fang. So, Tanzanite
Fang. And we're pretty well just
guessing on this. We'll start with
somewhere around
2600. And we'll try three. Um, these
have about I think 60 or 70 traded every
day. I did check already. Okay. Uncut
Onyx somewhere around 30
70. And we'll do three of these as well.
We can always adjust it if we manage to
buy
some. Dragon bones only have a 5 GP
margin. But look at that. We bought all
the antidonixes. That's awesome.
Um, gonna try to flip them for I don't
know,
3140K. Let's be a
little Let's shoot for the moon on this
one to start with. Yeah, I'll start with
doing like 4K. See how that goes.
10,000 and go.
26100. And we'll do the full 200 seats
because that's a really good margin.
Okay, so we actually bought one of the
tanite fangs and I believe um not many
have sold it. So we'll sell them
for so 26
9k. Think we're going to shoot high then
reduce the damp from
there. Wow, we got another Tanzanite
fang. Okay. Okay, we actually got all
the L runes in one go. Uh, now we just
have to check the price has not changed,
which I believe it may have. No, we
still sell them for 217. That's pretty
nice. Okay, we actually managed to sell
one of the fangs. That's awesome. Um,
sweet. That's a 90k we made right there.
That's
awesome. Okay, we actually sold all the
seeds for the snapdragon. That's pretty
sweet as well. That's 50k plus on that.
Perfect. Okay, we bought our last fang.
These snap dragon seeds are working
quite well. We're getting 1.2k on each
one. So, we flip the whole amount.
That's almost 200k. That'll be
awesome. Want to sell these for 27
[Music]
280. Okay, we got another Tanzanite
thing. Uh, we still have not sold our
other ones. I think we're going to
reduce these down quite a bit. Start
with
2660k and we'll start with 15k just so
we have a little bit of money left over.
Actually, we did manage to sell a large
portion of these. I don't know, maybe
we'll just leave them in there. Anaxes
and Tanzanite fangs need to sell
unfortunately. So, we really need to
start lowering these down. Uh, what do
we buy these for again? 31
[Music]
10k. Oh, wow. We actually sold a tan
fang already. That is awesome. Okay,
perfect. We bought another Tanzanite
fang. Uh well, I don't know if perfect,
but uh we bought another Tanzanite fang.
Okay, we sold off all the sharks.
Um I know it wasn't a huge margin on the
sharks. I don't think I'd really do
those again, but okay, we sold off all
our snap dragon seeds. That's awesome.
Actually, I don't remember how many in
total we got because we would like to
continue buying these actually. Okay. Um
so, we have Oh, nice. We sold one of the
fangs. That's great. Yeah, still seems
to be the 2GP margin. So, we'll sell
those for 132 while they're at
it. So, that's nice. Um, the Snapdragon
seeds have totally bought. Uh, 50 in
total. Perfect. And we're going to sell
those back for
27200, I
think. Something like that. Okay. And
we've uh fully flipped law rooms, which
is awesome. And we've sold a Onyx.
Great. Uh, so we got about 30k there.
That's going really well, actually.
279 277 and we do some nature
runes and 10,000's the limit for that.
Actually, we're going to pull this 10
pay up for
now. Oh, wow. We just sold one.
Interesting.
580 90k. We'll keep it at 90k. Let me go
ahead and buy one more of those since
they seem to be flipping pretty quickly.
Oh, the nature runes have totally
bought. Perfect. And we're selling them
for
279. Okay, we have sold another
Tanzanite fang. So, that is awesome.
We're definitely going to probably buy
more than one of these. We're almost
done buying the Zer scales. Still have
not sold them yet, unfortunately. But
that's okay. Um, these scales really
should be selling. So, I think we need
to change something. Maybe they drop
back down to 131. Yes, they did. Okay,
[Music]
there 31. Uh, that's pretty good
actually. Let me do some battle staffs.
8631 and we'll do a,000. These tend to
buy very quickly, which is awesome. Uh,
we sold off all these skills. That's
nice. All right, we sold a Snapdragon
seed, so we fully flipped that. That was
awesome. We got a gray march on those.
Um, but anyway, the battle savves have
pretty much sold. Uh, so or bought,
sorry,
8660 is what we're selling them
for. And we'll try buying one magic
fang.
Um, let's see.
2600. Just toss one in and see if we buy
it. Okay, we bought all those skills.
That's nice. Let's have a look here. And
we're going to sell them back for Oh, we
bought magic fang, too. Perfect. We're
selling back for 131, I
believe. Yeah. And we sold nature runes.
Perfect. Get the money back there. Magic
fang.
Um, I don't
know.
Maybe
26 average of 15k on the magic fang.
Maybe this might be too low, but we'll
find out, I
guess. 10,000 death runes. We'll just
leave those in there for a
bit. 10 night
fan
2600. Just go buy one more of those.
Let's check the battle staffs quickly.
E649. And we'll stump those. Um, we got
some snap dragons coming through pretty
quickly, which is nice. Um, death runes
are buying pretty quickly. Um, let's see
what else we got on the drop table here.
02k. Whatever. Um, same with this
tanzanite fang. Uh, we haven't bought it
yet. Our magic fang. Well, I'll leave
that for a little longer. Five GP raw
sharks. Yeah, sure. Why not? We got
money just sitting
here. Do 5,000 cuz we I think we did 5k
already or like 3 or 4k or something.
Um, so we bought all the death runes
actually. So, we'll quickly go turn
those around.
believe I hit the limit on that. So,
we'll just have to assume the the price
hasn't
changed
278 21. And we do some
arrows, 121, and 10,000. We've hit the
limit
roughly. Okay. Things are just nicely
selling all the time, which is cool cuz
all our scales are totally sold and we
flipped the max amount for that. Uh,
which is nice. Oh, we actually sold the
magic fang. So, that's nice. Um, might
go back and buy another one. I really
remember what it was for at this point.
This 25.90 probably. Um, at this point,
I think we're only going to flip one at
a time. So, we're not stuck with a bunch
of them, but we have to dump at the
end. Not a decent margin. Just the
amount traded isn't super high. 150k a
day. Uh, we'll do some of these.
1523, but not a whole lot. We'll start
with just uh
500. 47
times 100. It's not a whole lot, so it's
okay. Um the sharks we'll start selling
just cuz we want to clear our inventory
a little bit. I think we'll start
selling the sapphires. We just need to
focus on some of the quick moving items
really. Um these uncut onxes. My god. I
guess we'll just keep lowering them
down, but I guess people just do not buy
these very often.
$29.99. Okay.
It's pretty low. God
damn. Oh I that up, didn't
I? How much did I buy him
for? Oops. There's Should do chaos
runes. That's a 2GP
margin. 101 10,000 chaos runes. Might
get some of
those. We have 24 mil in the inventory,
but we only have 10 minutes left. It's
kind of an awkward timing. We're just
going to stick to some lowrisk items at
the end. Items I probably should have
done at the beginning because while they
are quick, uh, they are contested, so
they take a while to buy, but they do
buy pretty consistently. Like these
death runes are pretty much all sold.
Um, same with the uncut sapphires.
Honestly, I think we're just going to
sell things at this point. We have 8
minutes left. I'm pretty happy with how
we done how we done how we
did. And there we go. We're actually
getting a decent amount of coal near the
end. Um, so buys pretty quickly. Um,
just got to give it a little bit of time
really. Death runes are pretty much all
sold, which is nice. I think we're
selling this for 194 or something. Not
not massive margin or anything. Okay, we
are down to 5 minutes remaining. I think
we're going to take our buy prices out
for everything. Uh, just focus on
selling the remainder of what we have.
Okay, we have sold off all the coal
finally. Um, well, not finally, actually
was pretty quick. That's nice. We got 81
GP margin on that. That's about 10k from
the coal. Uh so we're just down to three
items left. So hopefully we can sell
them
off. Okay, so we're down to about 1
minute left. Um we've actually totally
sold the runarrows, which is nice. Take
those out. And we've sold some of the
Snapdragons at this point. Um so I don't
know, there's still a chance we might
sell some of
those. And yeah, uncut sapphires are
still selling, but that's pretty much
it. So we're down to 15 seconds left,
and we actually did manage to sell the
snap dragons. They completed all in one
offer, which is awesome. So, all we have
left is one item, which is pretty sweet,
to be honest. We're already over the 30
mil mark. Let's see how much we made.
First, we just got to sell these uncut
sapphires. So, we're down to 1 second
and we're done. So, timer's done. Uh,
we'll pull these sapphires out and see
how much we made. Okay, so uh we are
done. Let's head over to the left side
of the Grand Exchange and we will price
check how much money we actually made in
1 hour. Um, so I'm predicting about 500k
or something like that. Uh, so for 1
hour flipping Zol drops, we got
628k. So a little bit more than I
thought and actually pretty good. Um, so
definitely quite a bit better than any
other episode I've done where before.
Mind you, I did start with 30 mil. So
that would be kind of not fair to
compare. Um, but still I believe the
drops we were doing were actually quite
a bit better uh than any of the other
episodes. Um, beyond the fact that we
started with three times money. Um, so
if you guys have any other suggestions
for other boss drops I could do or any
other episodes in the future, please
leave a comment down below. And I hope
you guys enjoyed and I will see you guys
in episode 10.